women overwhelmingly do not fight for
marriages men put up with fat wives they
put up with wives that do not sleep with
them and they put up with controlling
wives all because they care about the
children but women will divorce men
because the man says please don't go to
the club sweetheart or maybe you don't
get your nails done for 7 years notice
how in her language she talks about how
getting your nails done is something
you're entitled to even though she
hasn't had her nails done in 7 years
ladies why is this stuff so important
why do you feel entitled to makeup Botox
and getting your nails done once you
have a child it's not about you you live
in a me me me me
me world and they forget that really
when you have children you're supposed
to dedicate your life to those children
your